hello everybody hope they are good the
last 24 hours have been really volatile
for Bitcoin I mean you can see how you
know they bring price down into this
blue box that's the idea that we're
talking about in yesterday's video they
actually even swap the lows okay and
then you can see how they push price
back up immediately okay and set that
reversal and right now if you notice
we're above the 4 Hour 50 okay so it's
not looking that bad
all right
um this volatility
I tell you it's a bless because we've
had very boring weeks before I mean
check what was going on here or here or
here you mean so to have some volatility
some of these days like for example the
ETF day or this pump or this reversal
okay all of these days
they are a gift for their Traders like
us
okay so we'll have to take advantage of
that volatility
and we have to also look in different
time frames to and try to understand
what is going on
in in this time frames of a day trader
okay what's going on in the one hour
time frame the four or time frame and
sometimes you have to go into the daily
time frame and that's what I did
yesterday I believe that most of you
follow me on Twitter because that's
where I started and what I have the most
followers and where I'm very active so
yesterday I posted this setup right
before going to bed I was 12 hours ago
and I took two longs
at 25 100 something all right two Longs
over there I opened one and I said
that's not enough size I have to open
more and I went with with some more
conviction okay so what I was telling
you yesterday is that we had a a problem
okay that's what I was telling you to it
and it was that if you notice here
okay this was when we were in this range
of between 31
000 and 20 about 30 000 between 31 430
000 if you remember we were calling for
this deviation
okay
um this time I was not calling for this
deviation I was calling for a new push
into this blue box
okay and then I push higher but
when I saw yesterday that we actually
swapped the lows and president want to
go lower
and I checked the volume we're gonna go
through that in a minute I thought hang
on this looks exactly the same okay so
then I pulled the volume indicator this
is on indicator that I don't use
multiple
for deviations from false moves it can
give you a good idea okay and I remember
that one of the reasons why I thought
that this was a deviation and I enter a
short a thirty one thousand four hundred
was the volume check this out okay this
is the volume of this pump and then of
this range usually when you see a
Breakout
you want to see a spike in volume okay
but if you notice that candle here this
big green candle
look at the volume
that was the volume there wasn't even
more than this candle for example right
so if you notice here you can see that
the volume was evening in fact going
down okay you can't even see that was
going down
let me add an arrow so you can see it
going down all right and here
what happened yesterday you had the same
case check this out okay notice the same
behavior you have many links to the
upside
but price cannot go through same as here
Works to the downside by Price cannot go
through okay and then suddenly erps a
big green candle or a big red candle
with a candle body attacking those lows
or those highs in this case all right
check that out here
and also here
right but if you check the volume
it's also going down
so sorry for the arrow
hang on
so if you notice
how can you choose this move
how could you choose this move because
the retail Trader what the written this
is okay you know we've set a lot of
weeks here if that's a support okay but
then they see a big red candle with a
candle body attacking those slopes and
closing where the wigs closed
and they said okay this is gonna go to
zero I'm gonna I'm gonna open shorty
okay this is gonna go lower same up
happening here people here I remember
please when it was a 31 500 people were
calling for 34k I have kind of like the
same Buffs here that's what I decided
yesterday to enter to enter along now if
you go back to the photo time frame you
can see how this developing okay it's
true I have to use this this was
something like this yesterday but then
when I saw that this was a deviation I
said hang on
this actually makes some sense to all
right so this is song song what I'm
looking for to happen at the moment
again it might not happen we have lots
of news announcements this week today's
going to be a quiet day regarding this
news announcements but tomorrow we have
CPI that's when I move the market we
also have the FTX scenario that they
might get an approval to liquidate some
assets
um first we've got PPI unemployment
claims is going to react crazy week so
again this prediction might not even
play out right but so far the first part
you can see how he's playing out which
you know if you can take advantage of
this the same way as I did you know
that's good because
it gives you at least a direction of the
short term right of course you don't
know if price is going to get here and
if it does it might continue higher who
knows because I don't know what the PPI
or CPI is going to be like all right but
this is the basic scenario that I have
in my head and that's what I reflected
in the chart all right so
what can we see do you've seen that stop
hunt to the downside
everybody calling lower prices
then you see the volume now enough
volume to the idea of the deviation
and then price overnight
in my case
is Bike Swap and reverses now
this is what I was expecting to happen
but
we got a major problem here
and and most of you probably notice
and is that this poem here
3 AM UTC time that's during the Asian
session so time we choose this move
I mean
I didn't choose this move to the
downside but I also don't truth this
move up so what is the Trap
was this the Trap
or was this the Trap
all right that's the question that I'm
asking myself all morning
and my conclusion is that
both of these moves were traps okay
I took this one I took advantage of this
took too long here
I closed them today at 26 200 right
before I started to make this video so
around here okay and I'm gonna explain
to you why again I might be completely
wrong and this might continue going
higher but this is the way I trade okay
if I have in 12 hours
a five percent profit without leverage
that was
that's not enough reason to take profits
okay
so I'm going to explain to you what I
think so far what I can say is you have
this drop
and then it reverses session and I
always tell you
and you might start to hear this more on
Twitter but I've been saying this for
I think more than a year
don't trust Asian pumps and that's part
also of the trading system I mean you
can go through you know different what
happened in the past and try to find
acms and I'll tell you they usually
don't end up well they tend to get
retraced okay most of them
I will probably tell you
plus 85 percent of them
dick every Trace within the next New
York session or the next Asian session
are there something that I also talk in
the course okay but
that's the thing about this institution
you have to be very careful with them
now this pump here in principle it's
very likely that gets retrace either
today
or in the next Asian session board there
is also a chance that it might be one of
those you know 10 15 and maybe
discontinues you know to continue going
higher if CPI tomorrow is good and at
the end the FTX
don't get the approval to liquidate
assets or if it's a
uh in this case sell the rumors buy the
news the opposite okay but if that's the
case then yes we're gonna go and hit
these two liquidity pools in the very
short term but what I see at the moment
is that you know
the chances are that if Asia pumped
this is not a place where I want to
enter new long so
um if you enter here
do whatever you want there is no
Financial advice
but I would be very careful and if you
can secure some profits it's never about
option okay you go here again a five
percent
five percent move what else you want
okay okay so
what I think is that usually
Asia pumps
then London holds and if that's the case
then New York will dump okay so if you
mark the sessions you'll be able to see
the Asia pumped here
okay that's your laser pump then London
should be holding in the Sun
bye
they are holding so far so far they've
pumped too okay hang on let me change
the color so it's not confusing
the colors always have to be this way
otherwise it doesn't work okay it's the
same as the weeks and liquidity pools
ACI is purple London is orange and New
York is white otherwise it doesn't work
guys so if you want to see something
like this then you need to see London
free tracing in the next two hours
back to the to to when you open the
session okay so you'll at the end you
know you might think that this is a pump
if they close here but no because they
are closing at the same price as they
are opening the price okay so if London
decided to retrace back into this level
then at the end you're gonna have Asia
pumping London holding can you just
ignore this noise and then that's when
the New York can reaches the whole Asian
move okay so that's the first scenario
if London decides to retrace this pump
here and comes back into this Zone by
2PM UTC time
then there is a high chance a high
priority than New York dumps
right that's the first thing now what
could happen if London doesn't do that
okay then if London doesn't do that
Moana watch The Sensation tonight
because then they have a high chance
also that they decide to dump so you
know we are basically not running to
favor higher prices as long as this ASM
pump is not retraced that's how strict
this trading system that I developed is
okay it doesn't let me go long as long
as this
pump in this institution gets retraced
because
it's something that I don't trust okay
again it might not get retrace in the
New York session it might not get
retrace in the Asian session then
that would be part of that 10 15 percent
of Asian punks that don't get rich
immediately
but they will get it at some point okay
and that could be then CPI
if FDX approval to sell PPI unemployment
claims could be anything right so I want
to go very careful this week so far I
tell you
with this trade here
I've I've done my week but of course I
want to enter into new trades now the
thing is I don't have that much pressure
now to enter your trades okay so and
also considering that tomorrow and on
Thursday we have lots of news
announcements
and that means that
first of all you can get stopped okay
because maybe you see a candle
like let me show you an example maybe
you can see a candle like this one okay
check out this candle
look to the other hand side you can get
stopped there
and then another week there so this
candlesticks are gonna happen this week
you're gonna see candles like this this
week okay what candles like I don't know
let's have to find some more some more
of those crazy candles
or for example a candle like this one
all right or these ones see these
scandals in news announcements days
they're very common okay or or this kind
of candle this candle is basically
screwing everybody okay long and shorts
all right so
you have to be very careful especially
on Wednesday and Thursday and that's why
I'm gonna be very selective with my
trace the rest of the week now if today
we get what I'm telling you if we see
London
here by 2 pm you this time then you have
the Asian pump London holes and New York
Dom's Theory okay
all right so I hope that was clear I
hope that I was clear in the chart now I
would like to check what the dollar is
doing because you know the dollar is not
well Bitcoin is not following the dollar
is been something quite bizarre okay you
can see
we have this Gap
we are talking about this Gap that it
needs to get filled all right but you
can see
the this was on Monday right at the
start on Monday all right
the dollar dumped
okay
and that's when Bitcoin
should have gone up by Bitcoin also
dumped and then yesterday
in the in midday and also overnight so
that's basically now when Bitcoin has
pumped the dollar has pumped too so why
is Bitcoin following the dollar is doing
the opposite okay so when that happens
then I tell you this chart this week
with a look at it because it's not it's
not been correlated with Bitcoin so it's
not going to give us any idea okay or it
can be quite misleading so usually
Bitcoin follows a dollar
I I need something that it's a fact
you can't go in any time frame then
you're gonna see that you can even go
into the weekly time frame and see when
the bull market and the bear Market
starts and finishes that's basically the
cycle of the dollar too all right but
you know at least this week
okay
um so far my attention is in this Asian
pump
I don't trust it all right now let's go
and check high blood Capital how it's
looking guys
Juan hablo Capital liquidation levels
and always the first thing that I check
is the Delta right so right now it's
pretty much at zero but you can see how
yesterday there was eight billion
dollars worth of short liquidations okay
which explains the shortest quiz all
right now if you check out the right
this is spikes we were talking yesterday
the spice were to the downside all the
way to 25 300. they took that zone so
you can see how Bitcoin follows the
liquidity and the next question is what
is the liquidity right now right so what
I see in the chart by looking at the
spikes at the right those are the
liquidations of high leverage Traders
the first thing that is that to the
upside we have here
some liquidations
are exactly
twenty six thousand four hundred okay
that's not well actually there is a lot
of liquidations up there right
there's qualifications over there so
that's going to be a zone of Interest
26.4 okay bro please check to the
downside look at this okay 25 994
204 Millions worth of long liquidations
we check again here another 204 Millions
at 25 700 and another 204 Millions at 25
200.
right so
these
is a lot of liquidity
they can see how the liquid is the
downside because when the original
Trader sees prices going up but the
little trivia is gonna do it's gonna be
chasing that price
okay that's also what happened yesterday
price was dumping here
and how many calls on Twitter
do so
of a deviation how many how many Traders
how many people were calling for a
deviation are the lows nobody was
everybody was calling a lower prices and
that's because the retail Trader is
programmed to think that when price is
going down they have to chase those red
candles
they have to go short and when price is
going up they have to open Longs and
that explains all these short
liquidations to the downside here that
they got squeezed at the sensation and
that also explains how those Traders or
new Traders decided to open Longs in
this
green candle right so that's where the
liquidity is right and at the moment
induce a big green candles all right
that's what they're also called
liquidity pools so now right now we go
to the recreational heat map
let's check what we've got here
all right so you can see here all right
a lot of liquidity
right below the the two previous lows
that's normal there is always liquidity
above the previous highs and below the
previous lows doesn't surprises me but
in yesterday this video we're also
talking about this zone of liquidity
okay around 26
726 800 so why not is it possible
the Bitcoin or imagine if London doesn't
retrace it's pumped today okay then you
know that New York is probably not going
to retrace today so that brings you to
the idea what about if this pump is not
finished they come and attack this song
before tomorrow's CPI or with a week
between tomorrow's API and then that's
when you can see price reversing all
right that's another scenario
to keep an eye on okay one more time
frame
look at these guys
right I love liquidity are 25 200 and
100 they took it
the liquidity to downside is increasing
at 23 500 still
and this is still quality of liquidity
Above This previous High okay do I think
we're gonna get this high
I mean so far I kind of look at these
targets because they are quite far away
all right and
to be honest
you know if you want to see this this
price getting hit do you need this week
really good news announcement so it's
something that I don't know but to the
downside three months time frame you can
see
that the liquidity in this Zone keeps
increasing and increasing and increasing
and I tell you something with what
happened yesterday with this drop
okay
and then you have this pump
levels new Traders open Longs because
they were chasing that daggering candle
which causes the liquidation Sia to
increase so you can see that okay the
market make it is chilling okay he's
chilling in his office and he's saying
okay
you know with all this Spike style and
reversals
the written 3D is going to continue
adding some more equity for me here you
know so when there is you know some bad
news
that can't justify a drop in price you
know hesitate but to drop price to this
Zone that's why it's very
dangerous
okay to be into swing trades at the
moment that's what I I always tell you
in weeks of news announcements go flat
into news announcements so tomorrow on
Thursday go flat into the news
announcements go flood into CPI go flood
into PPI and unemployment claims okay
and then if you want to take some scalp
some day trades go ahead but keeping
your risk very abused and managed okay
so if there is suddenly bad news channel
for example in Long
because that can happen in literally a
one hour candle okay
so that's pretty much everything that I
want to say in this video
now before I finish the video
I want to remind you that I'm currently
doing this campaign with being x one of
the top exchanges that doesn't require
kyc one of the only ones and we have a
campaign going on for this week you can
see all the rules and conditions here
but you can see event end time that's on
Friday night okay and basically the
campaign is that if you register and you
deposit fifty dollars you're gonna get
fifty dollars for free you get the 20
bonus for registering through the link
and the 30 bonus for depositing those
fifty dollars and keep it in there for
three days right and then you can also
do this uh condition
to get a hundred dollars rewards that is
five thousand dollars on trading volume
that might sound like a lot but I told
you yesterday too it's basically five
trades with one hundred dollars in times
10 leverage okay so it's pretty easy to
to achieve and also you'll have uh 10
discount on trading fees okay so so if
you want to support the content and and
you also want to take advantage of this
tasty rewards okay do you guys know I
don't have any paid groups I sell all my
analysis for free I don't shell any
coins but it's true that I work with
exchanges because I also get benefits on
trading fees discounts and I can also
give you some advantages like this okay
so if you want to support my content
please feel free to use the referral
link here okay make an account deposit
fifty dollars you get fifty dollars for
free and you'll also make me happy so
thank you so much guys for watching and
I'll see you soon